to know that there are some things that
you cannot know is mental health but to
not know things that you should know is
illness the wise man recognizes the
limits of his knowledge the foolish man
thinks he knows everything
chapter 71 ignorant of the Dao de Jing
this is part 2 I made another video on
this where I discussed that ancient
humans were clearly smarter than us they
were far more awakened and enlightened
to the collective whole of the human
race and our entire civilization well
then that the leaders that run the
entire show do now I mean you take into
consideration the leaders of
corporations the media governments all
over the world
it's beyond obvious that we're being led
by those who have selfish ambitions
those who are putting their own desire
for money power and fame before the
masses this is abundantly clear however
if the whole world was to start teaching
their children from I don't know grade
school on up the information contained
in the ancient wisdom of the daodejing
this world would improve far quicker
than most of us realize now if you're
not familiar with the doubt a Ching and
I'm going to read a few more of my
favorite passages in just a second but
if you're not familiar with a doubt a
Ching it translates to the book of the
way or the book of the way of virtue
depending on the dialect that used to
translate it and who wrote it and when
is a subject of debate however most
people believe that it was written by
Lao sue in the 4th century BC and when
you look at this whole book after having
read it and by the way it's only 81
chapters and each chapter is less than
one page in length and most chapters are
actually just a few sentences so you can
read it very quickly in less than a half
hour although you'd want to take more
time to reflect on it of course but when
you look at it from just the whole you
have to ask yourself who I mean
how did someone come to such incredible
enlightenment and knowledge I mean I
would venture to say and I can't prove
this this is just a theory then maybe
some of these proverbs or poems they've
been called different things but these
individual chapters some of them might
date back far earlier than 2500 years
just a theory not necessarily
but the question becomes and when you
read this you just see and know the
truth as you'll see as I share a few
passages here with you that I mean my
goodness somebody would have had to
observe and analyze numerous
civilizations the rise and fall of
numerous civilizations and numerous
leaders good leaders and poor leaders to
be able to come up with this information
it's absolutely incredible
so as I just read number 71 which is
ignorance which just I mean is there not
just brilliant that there are people out
there just think they know everything
but smart people wise people recognize
that no there are some things we just
cannot know it's just the way it is so
without further ado let me read a few
more passages to you opposites when
beauty is only a masquerade then it is
simply ugliness in the same way goodness
if it is not sincere is not really
goodness existence and non-existence are
incompatible the difficult and the easy
are mutually opposed the long and the
short the high and the low the loud and
the soft the before and the behind are
all opposites
each reveals the other the wise man is
not conspicuous in his actions or given
to too much talking when troubles arise
he is not irritated he produces but does
not hoard he acts but expects no praise
he builds but does not dwell therein and
because he does not dwell therein he
never departs now the part about this
that I want to discuss real quick is the
opposites that everything reveals each
other I mean this goes and I'm going to
make a video on the Emerald tablets the
as above so below that in this universe
part of the law of the universe is that
there's just an opposite to everything
light dark and everything in between I
mean you could even look at birth and
death that there is a rise in to your
peak and then a gradual decline so you
can say that the middle of each the
between birth and peak versus the peak
to death there's an opposite there - do
you see what I'm saying
and it's also worth mentioning the part
about good that you know if beauty is
only a masquerade than its ugliness in
the same way that if goodness isn't
sincere than it is in goodness I mean
isn't that true I mean is there any
debate about that let me move on to
number 6 the source which is very short
as you can see the
spirits of the perennial spring which by
the way perennial is infinite than
never-ending is said to be immortal she
is called the mysterious one the
mysterious one is the source of heaven
and earth
she is continually endlessly giving
forth life without effort I like how it
says she it's interesting because when
you look at ancient Egyptians as an
example women the females they were
running the show they were the leaders
were they not the hierarchy was a
matriarch just like in the animal
kingdom of elephants the the women lead
the way and there's been other
civilizations that have been the same
way I find it interesting that it refers
to as she as the giving forth of life
but that the universe is always giving
birth and everything completes itself
that everything ties together and the
source of all things is what creates and
we are all part of that source nikola
tesla discussed this into some detail
which I discuss in a few of those videos
as I'm sure most of you have seen so let
me move on now to 8 which is goodness
which we touched on briefly in opposites
true goodness is like water it nurtures
everything and harms nothing like water
it ever seeks the lowest place the place
that all others avoid this is the way of
the DAO for a dwelling it chooses the
quiet meadow for a heart the circling
Eddy in generosity it is kind in speech
it is sincere in authority it is order
in action it is gentle and movement it
is rhythm because it is always peaceable
it's Uvas and refreshes I love the part
how it discusses early on that like
water it seeks the lowest place the
place that all others avoid this is the
way of the Dow this is I mean you could
tie this into Christ
you know guys anyone that needs help the
people that truly need help are the ones
that usually most people the masses will
seem to avoid those who need it most
like people that are addicts people that
have poor a lot of people need a helping
hand and by helping me and I'm not
saying here's a bunch of money but think
about it water seeks the lowest place as
does goodness doesn't that make sense so
those out there who are truly good they
don't just avoid the lowest areas those
are the places that be
seek just like water and water gives us
everything let me move on to nine
prudence
if you continue filling a pail after it
is full the water will be wasted if you
continue grinding an axe after it is
sharp the edge will wear away who can
protect a house full of gold and jewels
excessive fortune brings about its own
misfortune or money more problems - in
true merits to earn a good reputation
you must be prudent this is the way of
the DAO think about it guys I've had a
very interesting life I've had I've been
well-off I've lived poor everywhere in
between
and I can tell you that honestly it just
seems that more material materialism or
money more the more focus you have on
riches it's man it doesn't bring a pot
it doesn't bring upon you what you truly
seek and the world is seeing this as a
whole we are as a global civilization
are largely living a more materialistic
life than ever before arguably and yet
you can say that there's more suffering
in this world than has ever been of
course that's debatable - right I mean
look at world war two the whole world
suffered but the point is this
materialism does not bring happiness
well it does so but it's very very
short-sighted
it's very anything about anyone to buy
something new might be excited about it
but how often before that wears off
before they want the next best thing but
it surely makes a great point so let me
move on to number 11 which I which is
called materiality which I shared in my
prior video but it's so important
especially in 2017 and it ties right in
without what I was just saying about
materialism so how to read this probably
in part 3 as well you can't leave this
one out a we all may have 30 spokes but
its usefulness lies within the empty hub
a jar is formed from clay but its
usefulness lies within the empty centre
a rome is made from four walls but its
usefulness lies in the space between in
the same way matter is necessary to give
form but the value of reality lies in
its in materiality that is everything
that lives has a physical body but the
value of life is measured by the soul
amen
right I mean oh my goodness it's so true
the
value of life is measured by the soul
and you can also say that soul is the
source of all things that make up well
say a room of four walls at all
everything here is made up of what comes
from the source but the measure of it is
what's within it just like the measure
of a person isn't what they look like
it's what's within their character their
soul number twelve seek spirit too much
light blinds the eye too much noise
defens the ear too many spices dull the
taste too much exercise weakens the body
the pursuit of great riches leads to
ruin the wise man attends to the inner
truth of things and he is not fooled by
outward appearances he ignores matter
and seeks the spirit I can tell you this
from my own life experiences my goodness
and many others will tell you this in
fact you can just looking simply into
celebrity culture or the powers that be
whether it be politicians and world
leaders or even leaders of corporations
they're all trying to achieve something
that they just cannot fulfill and that
it ultimately leads to their ruin they
have many problems divorces terrible
rights to ship with their kids total
disgrace and going down like the dark
end of the addiction and everything else
we know this is this not true and yet
the ancients were talking about this at
least closer to 2500 years ago the
top-two makes you think doesn't it what
was just as true back then thousands of
years ago is unbelievably true today
humans haven't changed have we now to
close this up for this one video I'm
going to go back and read I read this
from the last video but the very last
chapter of the book 81 true words not
too long but this is just freaking
brilliant true words are often
unpleasant Pleasant words are often
untrue those who know the truth do not
argue those who argue do not know the
truth
scholars are seldom the wisest men
wisest men are seldom scholars those who
steal from others impoverish themselves
those who give to others become rich
those who fight do not win those who win
do not fight this is the way of the Dow
is that not brilliance honestly again
when you stop
you reflect on this entire book in its
hole it's unbelievable like I said just
how true that wisdom was thousands of
years ago which and I also suspect dates
back for them 2500 years as I stated
earlier but just how applicable it is
today so I highly recommend this book I
hope you enjoyed this me sharings just
some insight on this but I highly
recommend it I think you should buy it
and again this is something that should
be taught to every child starting from
the grade school level on upwards
anyways I'll leave it at that I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight like and
subscribe let me a comment let me know
what your thoughts are and I have many
more videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics take care everybody